hello internet welcome to the Reuben
report I'm the official mascot of the
sochi games dave rubin I've got Jen
Hoffman and Gerald McCullough with me
and we are gonna get right to it we're
going to start with bill nye the science
guy bill nye he debated creationist ken
ham on msnbc.com last night I'm pretty
sure you probably know who Bill Nye the
Science Guy is but if you don't know who
can am is he runs the creation museum
which is a 27 million dollar museum
based on the literal belief in the
creation of the world as recounted in
the Bible before we get to the debate
let's just show you a couple images from
the creation museum because it is a
piece of work so what you're seeing here
first is on the left that's a Utah
Raptor not a velociraptor from Jurassic
Park that's a Utahraptor and on the
right is Cain murdering able they
believe that these things happened at
approximately the same time drama to
about such such drama what we have here
uh on the left is a painting of the
Grand Canyon after the flood the
Biblical Flood the Grand Canyon which
which they claim made the Grand Canyon
literally on the right is a as a door
from the culture in crisis exhibit
because you know if gay people have sex
then we get tornadoes and floods and
things of that nature uh two more for
you uh the left that's where Adam names
the animals uh and on the right is Adam
and Eve in the Garden of Eden and of
course these again these are literal
things that they believe happened in
this museum played by Demi Moore said
that does look like a girl is like a
young lady to Cardassia uh and finally
uh on the fourth this is moses in the
biblical Authority exhibit on the left
and the right again is the culture in
crisis exhibit so you can see if you if
you walk around with two giant tablets
that tell you what the Ten Commandments
are you're not gonna be killing people
and shooting people and things like that
you giant tablets and a backpack yeah
it's a lot to deal with just a couple
other quick little things so yes they
believe in this museum that
humans coexisted with Dinosaurs so
there's a chance that Jesus rode a
velociraptor in Bethlehem they believe
that the Biblical Flood as we said
created the Grand Canyon and that the
earth is only 6,000 years old okay we've
set that up so they debated creationism
first evolution I think we know which
side Bill Nye was on Jen I know you
watched and you were tweeting up a storm
part of me was thinking when they were
doing this whole thing it was the
number-one trend on Twitter which I was
actually happy about because it was like
wow people are paying attention to
science but what he was thinking right
or not or making fun of it but partly I
was thinking you know we're legitimizing
something we're putting the lamont equal
footing and that's my problem yeah a lot
of people complaining saying the film i
should have even debated him in the
first place because by debating him he's
acknowledging that creation isn't even
exists and is a possibility somewhere in
the realm of science that being said
they're real things at stake here you
know he's a teacher who's teaching
creationism rather than evolution to his
students so bill nye obviously i think
had a personal responsibility he felt he
had a personal responsibility to take on
this debate may be in order to save
science in order to save it from other
people that are kind of hijacking
science or discrediting science around
every corner so I get the thing about it
not being on even footing because one is
kind of I don't know completely made up
based on you know I don't have anything
you know and the other has been
immeasurable science as Bill Nye kept
going back and proving again and again
last night but I think the debate was
more culturally relevant than we'd be
scientifically relevant well I missed it
but did not hear there wasn't much of a
debate that they're more talking points
and back and forth engage in a
conversation well it's a 21st century
debate which is not like a real old
school debate where people genuinely
debate it's like you talk man I toss
when you talk like I talk so
unfortunately we you don't get like that
the real bounce back thing they wanted
to have that in order i think that would
be appropriate there's lots of different
formats for a debate and this is more of
a presenting information kind of debate
rather than exactly it wasn't like they
were trying to slug it out and in the
end really crown a winner there i think
the problem with it is is that first you
know you had him go and explain for
about a half hour straight all these
things that kind of just went in circles
so basically in the beginning he was
just like wow the address right so mr.
larceny and he had was at mark I was
forget his first name kentk ahead so
Kenny I went first and introduced
himself and kind of did the UM from
Australia so you might not understand
what I'm saying thing was just the worst
version sorry Australian yeah not even
mate and went on to kind of you know
just explain stuff without ever really
backing science and said he questioned
the methodology instead he questioned
science overall instead he didn't really
present any sort of case for his side
rather than very small detractors from
the other side right so do you guys
think the people was in the case though
they just choose to ignore science as
opposed to come come back with something
that proves their beliefs right i mean i
think it was a lot of faulty arguments
he brought on some other people video
evidence of other scientists he knows it
also happened to be Christians right he
brought on some other you know evidence
by saying he teaches in a classroom he
teaches children observational science
of something that you can observe it was
kind of like pictures or didn't happen
seriously he was like well if you
haven't observed it then it couldn't
have happened meanwhile we have history
in China and other places it's been
written recorded four million Aaliyah
the millions of years that was obviously
observed verse one book and this is the
thing i'll just say about the bible
pieces in the Bible as his observational
evidence that's also very flawed because
the Bible was written supposedly by over
40 different people over span of 15
hundred different years so soon the
telephone game for so many years this is
what happened and you tell somebody they
tell somebody and always changes right
so do you guys think there's any room
for these things to exist together
because it seems to me you couldn't
admit that you don't know how it all
started and you can say well maybe the
Big Bang did it but then what was before
that and the gases and all that guy
thing and then still so you'd have some
belief in a higher powers like but then
still believe in science it seems like
we don't have any room for believing in
both in America right well I think you
know a quantum physics in a way is that
in the fact that it's you know like
energy tracks like energy and everything
is energy and energy isn't doesn't
dissipate I think that that there's a
religious feel i believe to quantum
physics but it's all based in science I
mean that's kind of what I gravitate
towards yeah and also think we can't
explain sometimes we'd like to explain
by just completely making things up
because it makes us feel better makes us
feel good to feel like there's
something higher than us are more
important than us controlling it I also
believe in that sort of observational
science that he was saying you know
people say I had a feeling I just know
something was there but it was the ghost
of your dead grandmother right or
whether you feel like you were just
saved you know the minute you just
missed a car accident you feel like oh
wow I just know something was watching
over me I mean as you're saying that
could be related to a quantum physics
energy thing we don't understand and I
think the point in my whole rambling
thing right now is the ability to say we
don't understand but we're going to try
to use certain methods to try and
understand it that fit within certain
guidelines so like Bill Nye was going
look and I think he ended it he
mentioned that a few times he said
whatever we don't know I'd like to learn
I'd like to be proven wrong he's open to
that I feel like on the creationism
sides like nope this is the way it had
to happen well not open to poking holes
in our theory we're not open to learning
new things and that's the problem right
so isn't the real issue here is just the
leap of faith that I guess every person
either does make in their life or
doesn't make in their life you can
either say I'm gonna question this whole
thing or I just there's a lot of things
that I don't understand i'm never gonna
send so i'm gonna make this leap of
faith and just believe in something that
can't be proven and that's that's where
there's evidence in front of you don't I
brought some he did you leave over no
that's what the so basically you know
Bill I brought some and especially cuz I
from Kentucky was even kind of almost
more like an in-your-face but he brought
some Kentucky limestone and he said look
this I'm stone here through the fossils
in it and do what we can show through
dating is way way older than 6,000 here
she said if the earth was only 6,000
years old as you say then there's
absolutely no way this can even exist
then he brought the physical
observational evidence but is that
really good evidence doesn't matter if
you if you're taking that leap of faith
then the evidence doesn't matter you say
well I've can carbon-date this back a
million years but big damn what
direction or I think there's a certain
mentality people that are willing to
look at you know base what they think
off of questions and what they don't
know versus people just want to decide
like this is what I know I don't hear
anything else I'd you know this is what
I believe I don't you know I don't care
what you think I don't care what
information you have in front of me I'm
just gonna believe this yes for people
sometimes I think you just be told what
to believe and not question and to go on
though I heard it's dangerous wild world
out there yeah and you might be afraid
that you're not going to be taken care
of by a higher power if you start to
believe in these crazy
scientific things which is strange to me
because believing in whatever your
version of God is entirely and placing
all your faith and that seems a lot less
like you've a lot less power and control
and soft responsibility over yourself
than believing in science so I don't
really understand that well we wake up
to our belief in Santa Claus but we
don't with the battle I believe in
something like that right yeah right as
kids you all blow Santa Claus is real
and you're like oh and then it's a boy
there's no way that that's real right
that's true right like at 11 by 11 if
you're not on board like Santa's not
real like you're nuts but somehow this
thing you're not nuts so final thought
on this one thing that i did find very
refreshing about it was that we actually
were talking about science in america it
was the number one trending on twitter
as i said shouldn't we have a science
guy on TV every night like what did that
feel like it actually like felt like it
was removing a little pain go ahead no I
used to have a science show he did he
did but don't we need a more mainstream
place for it instead of all the screen
versus we have is like a doctor odds or
a duc de sanjay pepper type person and
their role unfortunately even though
these people are both very smart
achieved men who are physicians and
understand the human body and they're
not necessarily scientists that's the
closest we have is the doctor with
health and science is it instead of how
does it relate to you you know it's not
just science let's think of it let's we
didn't want to talk about stars and
space and physics right man we don't
have a big on the internet exactly we
don't really have anybody who's kind of
the mascot for science unless you're
going to like a deep cable channel you
know when watching maybe Mythbusters we
don't have on a regular news a regular
go-to person we kind of like our news
fast and easy and sometimes science is
not you it's not easy to explain science
in a 60-minute bit which is what a lot
of our entertainment interest right well
that's my men was 16 literally it's not
that easy a finishes I'm a big advocate
of PBS I love PBS has some very you know
articulate shows and information but
it's you know it's not Dallas and it's
not CSI the people become more
interested in science will have more
science segments because again the big
networks are all you know they pay
attention to the advertisers so if
people say we'd like to hear more about
science will get more about science
there's no evil conspiracy to keep us
from science maybe there's certain
factions of conservatives that would
like to keep us from that but overall
it's really if we say we want science
and we start one of science programs
will get it on television
alright well i hope you want a little
sign so we gave you a little signs
they're pretty sure we saw the whole
thing so there you go okay let's move
out to syria because it sort of been
pushed away now that Iran has taken over
the sort of bigger world stage picture
at the moment January actually marked
the most amount of people killed in
Syria in the entire conflict 6,000
people that brings the total up to a
hundred and thirty six thousand people
just crazy completely crazy there's
about two million people displaced in
Syria already and what I wanted to talk
about was that so John Kerry who's our
secretary state obviously he was quoted
by Lindsey Graham Senator Lindsey Graham
saying bless you saying bless you we are
at a point now when we're going to have
to change our strategy talking about
Syria then the State Department
immediately backtracked on that and said
that that's not true that everything's
okay not look we John Kerry was calling
this guy Hitler we almost went to war
then they sort of said they were getting
rid of the chemical weapons it looks
like maybe five percent or out the
killing is still going on so I don't
want to get into all the minutiae of
Syria because it's it's a lot of stuff
but what this was making can anyone
trust anything that America is doing any
more like you can can we trust that
either Kerry is making the right
decisions or even that we even here
remotely anything close to it wasn't it
a kind of a he-said she-said thing that
was what mccain it's what mccain and
lindsey grammars said they heard versus
a woman saying no I was in the room and
this is what was said she said that his
words were also manipulated so they took
certain aspects of what he said in
twisting towards you what they wanted no
hear that reporter let me ask you one
thing what is the big deal with Kerry
saying what we're doing isn't working
we've been working on stuff with Sarah
since what they were established as a
nation to think in 1947 since 1947 we've
helped stage crews in their country
we've actually WikiLeaks has shown that
we've sent them money we've sent money
to their anti you know government
propaganda TV news network we've sent
them money we've sent them equipment
we've sent everything not Syria the
government but we've sent the rebels
basically money and equipment everything
about their own country we're still
doing it there's proof through WikiLeaks
so if Kerry was like hmm you know what
this has been going on for I don't know
sixties years maybe we need to change
our strategy oh gee yeah BFD
well that's sort of my point is whether
fruit and area we can deal it if
somebody in America is finally gonna
actually admit that maybe we need to
change strategy maybe we need to stop
playing World Police maybe we need to
stop being involved in everything so
much to try to control i get that there
next to israel i get that they have
interested in Russia I understand we're
trying to protect ourselves through this
but maybe leading it's just like back
off and maybe we need to let people like
John Kerry jus they're supposed to do
which is assess the situation and give
their honest opinion unless someone like
John Kerry to either say yes we're on
the right track or no we need to you
know read I think we're so I'm on board
what you're saying there but to me it's
like whether what John Kerry said behind
closed doors was correctly quoted by a
Lindsey Graham or whether it was
incorrectly quoted by Lindsey Graham I
feel like we don't trust our politicians
and we don't trust our media and we
don't trust the State Department so when
I read this article I was like I don't
believe any any and i gave them as long
as they say what we want them to say ah
yes the great that's the rub yeah I
don't trust them either right I think I
understand exactly what you're saying I
feel like I could imagine that certain
Republican would want to manipulate what
John Kerry said it's in order to
specially to take down the position
Hillary Clinton tus this isn't really
just about John Kerry this is that the
Democrats and how they're handling fall
in foreign policy this is about saying
that John Kerry was in the right place
that Hillary Clinton didn't do her jobs
that always will come down to her in the
fear of her winning the election in 2016
yeah then you have the media wantin to
sensationalize a story which is a small
he said she said which should have been
on page god knows what but instead
they're gonna make it a big thing
because it's like the soap opera of
government we had like Lindsey Graham
and like John McCain and everything
together Lindsey Graham and John became
why are they always together Ian and
kicking it together yeah they're very
you have the same opinion you know I
lose an Arizona for over 10 years and
John McCain's obviously a very prevalent
there and he was a reasonable man I
always really liked him and I'd I was
probably going to vote for john mccain
until he took sarah palin on as a
running mate and then lately it's just
I'm glad I didn't because I don't know
where this craziness is right now then
you started dating lindsey graham and
the whole thing whether [ __ ] um alright
so let's move away from the he said she
says I think we're kind of agreed we
don't know what the truth is on that so
just a little bit about Syria have we
just given them a green light to kill
but I was completely against going to
war but by not doing anything and now
maybe they're getting the chemical
weapons out and Russia's still
arming Assad and we're arming the rebels
and Iran's helping Assad and it's like
have we just given them a license just
kill as many 136,000 papers is there
anything that we I don't think serious I
mean I think I think because of our
24-hour news situation now we're more
aware of it but I don't think Syria is
something new i think the things like
this have been going on for a very very
very long time right but is there
anything we can do it is like they do
they know that we're not going to do
they know we're not gonna do anything so
then it just in in bolsa both sides of
our mouths instead we're saying well we
support this government actually
happened we've actually asked was a
prime minister over there right then
we've asked him to step down I think
Obama officially is asked him president
ish live a president assad i was heard
the Prime Minister president there so
you ask the president there out loud to
step down and then kind of like passive
aggressively funded things behind their
back you know funded basically you know
the stuff for the rebels on it over to
rise up funded anti-government
propaganda over there so i think my
point in this in the end is if we are
going to be doing stuff like that and
understand we can't tell every what
we're doing we have to kind of live at
military operations as you get in
trouble but why can't someone using
position in our government say we've
been making mistakes and maybe we should
try something new because as you said
we've been doing the same thing for this
isn't anything new it's been going on
for years and years and similar things
are happening with other country other
countries and heather has forever yeah
well alright so speaking of other
countries and mistakes the sochi
olympics are starting on friday and i
mean already this is looking like a
disaster between obviously all the
anti-gay stuff that everybody's hearing
about and the threat of terrorism which
every day they keep leaking new
information that something may go down
and just last night I saw a report on
NBC that the second people are getting
off the plane in Sochi when you turn
your phone on the hackers immediately
have access to your entire phone now
comes they are killing all the stray
dogs in Sochi as well a pest control
company which has been killing dogs in
Sochi for years because they have to
have some sort of animal control as told
the AP that they have a contract to
exterminate more animals during the
Olympics because they don't want people
getting bitten and I guess seeing stray
animals on TV and things like that we've
got a quote from the general of the pest
control firm he said a dog ran into the
fisht stadium we took it away god forbid
something like this happens at the
actual opening ceremony
this would be a disgrace for the whole
country and now we have a quote also
from lawmaker in Sochi taking the dogs
off the street is Russia's
responsibility to the international
community and their elimination is the
quickest way to solve the problem all
right so look I'm a dog guy so this I
immediately saw this story and I don't
want to see all these animals killed and
of course all the gay stuff is horrible
and there's all kinds of other human
rights problems there so should we just
not be surprised by this in all kinds
and God knows what China was doing with
dogs right you four years ago or you
know whatever was so yeah exactly so how
much of a right do we even have to
complain when countries have to
supposedly do what they have to do to
clean up the place well I think they're
also they're justified the fact that
this is a threat to you know the amount
of tourists are about to come into the
into sochi and the problems that these
wavy and non rabia dogs could have you
know with kids etc and in in the games
the different events you know I i don't
i don't know if you know and they're
talking about saying they're gonna build
dog kennels but heavy yeah but they
haven't said anything they have it done
this is rush on man yeah they're killing
they're coming the dogs they haven't
even denied it in this company that was
subcontracted out to do it as admitted
openly that they're euthanizing the dogs
we don't know if they're shooting that
more casually yeah we don't know what
they're doing with these dogs look i
don't know if you've noticed but you've
seen all the the reporters are starting
to get there and revive and so she ate
if you've seen the reports than coming
in people are saying it's erect the
hotels don't have running water when
they do it's brown door knobs are
falling down some of the ceilings are
caving in and people have reported stray
dogs running in a hotel rooms so
obviously what we're seeing is so she
does not have their act together they're
a country that I think really wanted to
showcase and this you know in front of
the national international community how
Russia is glorious it was like make
benefit for glorious nation show up so
she and Russia and I don't think they
were prepared so I think this is just
another one of their hysterical
scrambles to make Russia look better was
like round up all the dogs and it is a
legitimate concern you want people
getting bit but obviously if your
country is such such to being close to a
third world and country in certain areas
where it's over run by the main
Korean was in Austria probably like are
you kidding me with them not getting the
Olympics as giving it to a country so
ill-prepared right so all right so I
want to make this all about the dogs but
should we have two separate Olympics
this is what I'm start anything we need
to have a gin olympics for the civilized
nations that have basic human rights
look everyone does bad things but basic
human rights you treat your women
equally you treat your gay people
equally it's gonna be a small group of
Olympics and that one well then we can
make our weave in it yeah I'll bet
you're right because your throat right
since the city yeah we're exactly right
with the small areas better Hollywood
would have one right oh you know there's
parish priests Kelsey in Paris what's
the gay section of a very good but
really should we have is it have we
gotten to a point in the world where
everything is so interconnected that
when they had the Olympics a hundred
years ago you didn't know about
everything necessarily i was going on in
every country now we have everything
instagram than mind and it's like you
can see you can literally see all the
human rights abuses so do we have to
have some list like you if you want to
play with the adults you have to have
basic human rights and and i understand
that this would exclude probably sixty
percent of the country a lot of it and
also there will be a lot of
discrepancies about what constituted
human rights is it there equal pay for
men and women is it that you don't gel
people without any recourse and all of
our legal systems and penal systems are
so different and attitudes and i think
what this is all about is trying to say
there is some sort of acceptance and i
think this is good cuz it's making
people aware of the way people live in
different countries and Russians have
different attitudes and americans and
forget that Americans have different
attitudes in most of the world so maybe
it's us not that maybe we have a higher
standard of living we should be really
grateful instead of going out go your
streets are overwhelmed augs and you're
killing then maybe be like wow you live
in a country where you actually live in
fear that packs of dogs my rx8 you're
home by the right come on we live in a
country that sending drones halfway
across the world they've been blowing up
weddings yeah that's was I think a lot
people then protest us by saying that
you don't even have your not even
sending your own people in a war anymore
you're descending drones in and I think
did a lot of problems that the US has
that are completely different than any
problems the rest of the world can
relate to and vice versa so be really
difficult to come up with a bullet
pointed list of what we threw except
because we're very different culturally
even if we have very close proximity
because of Technology yeah all right
well let's talk about something that we
all have no matter where you are in the
world and that is sugar we've done a lot
of stuff on dieting and health on the
show we talked a lot about aspartame but
sugar maybe Mike Bloomberg was right a
new study in the journal of american
medical association jama has said that
sugar is doing more damage to our bodies
than we originally thought added sugars
according to most experts are far more
harmful to our bodies than naturally
occurring sugars this is when you put a
spoonful of sugar and something as
opposed to eating an R enter sign like
that the US government hasn't issued a
dietary limit for added sugars like it
has for calories fat sodium etc that's
why when you have a coke and it has
however much sugar in it it's literally
like 20 spoonfuls and they're allowed to
do that and sugar is classified by the
FDA as generally safe which allows
manufacturers to add unlimited amounts
of any food so it's interesting because
America we sort of got off sugar a
couple years ago and everybody was doing
the diet soda thing and then the last
two years diet soda has disappeared
because of all the chemicals is this
just obvious stuff that we should all
know that you should not what you're
saying adding sugar yeah one can of soda
is twice or three times as much as the
sugar you should one can of giada is
twice a three much yeah three times as
much as I mean like that literally like
20 spoonfuls of sugar let's not forget
it's high fructose corn syrup which I
know we've talked about a thousand times
which is why the FDA also is not coming
out against it the way they do for fats
and other things because we put this
corn syrup in so many different things
yes murs are so involved in using corn
instead of using regular sugar that if
the FDA were suddenly come out and say
look sugar is bad for you which it is
which has pretty much been proven in
every single way and you'd have a panic
and farmers would lose money and the
corn industry is highly subsidized right
it's usually subsidize yeah do you have
a problem there with both like the
government saying that we supported by
subsidizing it than the same time if
they say that it's bad for you you'll
have a mass panic in this country no one
would you do themselves but server makes
you sick makes you fat it makes people
living on eggs it makes you tired I mean
who doesn't know this by now yeah so
what is the alternative to this because
are you a sugar if you were if you had a
coke and a diet coke in front of you
what are you done soda guy not Soto
after that said you know as far as
people that are smoking the things
drinking alcohol that soda is probably
the worst thing you can do for your body
so as I said before it is bus Bloomberg
right I lived in New York City at the
time during the the ban he wanted the
big ban and he was even pushing it
literally as he was being pushed out of
Gracie Mansion but was he right
Bloomberg was absolutely wrong by making
a sugar band because we live in the
United States of America and in America
people should be free to choose I think
the biggest problems that people don't
take personal responsibility for
themselves so everyone wants the FDA to
ban something or the government to say
something's not good for you look we
need to be presented with the
information so the FDA should be giving
us clear information about what their
studies have found and maybe help us
with some guidelines but it's not up to
individual cities or people to ban
things that aren't of a median eminent
danger instead give us the info and let
people decide right so I'm on board that
Miriam the donation can I don't want to
see it that is not what we're doing at
the creations but I'm on board that idea
that we should have the freedom to do
whatever we want if you want to buy a
big-ass o at 7-eleven you should be
allowed to but isn't there partly an
issue there that people are just sort of
dumb not only people are kind of dumb
but they don't want to know what the
truth is and they're uneducated how
would they even get the information they
can teach you something in grade school
about what the FDA retreat they taught
us that years and they're never kind of
that kind of evaporates from our now
right so that lasts till what about
fifth grade media and then must be
Darwinian at this point I'm so over it
at this point I'm like look if people
want to drink soda and be fat and be
unhappy be lazy me depressed and then my
self medicate themselves with all the
pharmaceutical drugs take care of all
the problems they've caused by eating
think food that isn't good and not
exercise god bless you oh yeah i mean
i'm serious i think it really is
personal responsibility and i do think
there is a little bit of trouble with
access to the information and that's the
problem because when you have a lot of
corporations kind of with vested
interest in the media when you have
lobbyists that are able to kind of get
in the pockets of politicians the access
to information isn't as fair so this is
kind of not the point of this whole
sugar thing but if you get the money out
of politics you have to make sure that
our media in some way it least has to
say who there
owned and sponsored by not stop saying
anything but the media's say what they
want but make things a little more
transparent we'll have more informed
people think people are starting to be a
little bit more aware especially with
the internet over net neutrality went
out the window I think I'd you know
we're talking about sugar you gave me
net neutrality money out of politics but
that's the thing there's no simple
answer to all this and the reason why
after talking about it for a few minutes
I actually want to pass out of bang my
head against a totally as I know I can
get me a diet coke is that there's just
there's no way to talk about this
without talking about all the different
factors that contribute into it you
can't have a conversation with it sugar
bad for you and should we drink it
without knowing everything surrounded by
the sugar culture in this country and
why you know continues yeah well I hope
you are drinking water while you are
watching this that is the key i actually
just switched to reverse osmosis water
this week I don't even know really what
it's a good it's very good correct i
don't know exactly it's cherish it's
well i guess regular water is osmosis
and now I'm reversing and I go to like a
place with a jug and they fill it up for
a quarter very i guess nice people man
la for a year I know why he was anything
worse all right speaking of white people
uh Mark Zuckerberg mr. Facebook you
might have saw this last week he is very
white he's extremely white uh so he and
three or two of his other billionaire co
founders of facebook and how much they
made on one day on Facebook last week
4.5 billion dollars yeah 4.5 billion
dollars so this is one day last week
Zuckerberg gained 3.2 billion himself
elevating his fortune to twenty seven
point four billion uh he added 12.4
billion to his network last year Dustin
Moskowitz co founder of Facebook gained
nine hundred forty million he's the
youngest billionaire on earth I like we
put on earth there uh Mars holy
situation and a 29 years old uh is eight
days younger than Zuckerberg and Sheryl
Sandberg Facebook COO became one of the
world's youngest female billionaires
just a couple other numbers for you
Facebook rose 14.1 percent the stock
that is 261 dollars and eight cents and
this file quarterly resolve
it's where the revenue rose 30
sixty-three percent to 2.5 nine billion
of course Zuckerberg has donated a lot
of money just donate a billion dollars
Silicon Valley communication foundation
they're putting computers and things so
they can watch us all the time and all
that kind of stuff okay should we be
angry at these people that not the one
percent of we've talked a lot about on
the show that the one person is
something like three hundred thousand
dollars so it's not the one percent but
should we be a little annoyed at the
save point ooo 1% the guys the billions
the billions in bill and what are some
one that said that he has more wealth
than anyone could know what to do in one
lifetime wasn't there I'll say I said
that because yeah what can you do with
all that money I mean even if he does
good stuff with all this money I'm not
besmirching the good name of Mark
Zuckerberg but even if he's doing good
stuff with it he's too much right like
how do we decide what's too much I don't
give me an answer answer higher economic
god we don't I mean people are able to
make money he wasn't some person look
you could say that he had some came from
some sort of elite privileged people can
argue that just by saying that he was a
white male attending a private school he
went to Harvard jajaja but the thing is
look he's a self-made person who had an
incredible idea that he saw through from
beginning to end and then he got
everybody in America than everybody in
the world on board so he's being
rewarded and we can say is the reward
fair as a person who was trying to find
a cure for cancer or someone teaching
children are they worth more than
someone who invented Facebook and in
this country and in this world yes they
are yeah everyone's on facebook it's
something we all use they've managed to
mine all of our information and
advertise to us and and they're doing a
lot more things that are going to creepy
and weird in order to make this money
but that's kind of when you see that's
when you see it get more involved once
too in order to go from something that
makes millions and millions of dollars
you need to be invested into something
that's kind of shifting the game or
shifting people's perceptions or
manipulating the people using your
product and that's where he's gone with
it so that's why he is all the money so
again the only way to shut down somebody
making a gazillion dollars is by people
saying out on use Facebook anymore but
who was gonna regulate it like the
government right and believe I'm on
board that libertarian strain of like he
built it like it's his let him do it but
there it seems to me we have this such
an income
an equality thing right now and Obama's
making that you know what he says he's
going to be like the last three years of
his presidency and all that that we're
gonna I feel like we're gonna start
having riots on the streets when people
really figure out a graduation yeah yeah
well look Zuckerberg represents what
people want the reason why people don't
ride is the idea that some day they'll
be part of the one percent the reason
why most people aren't angry with the
one percent is because in their head
they imagine that it's only a few years
or that one bright idea to become part
of it so that's why yeah doesn't the
Facebook thing hafta burst because we've
also talked about that a lot here that
there is definitely a fatigue with this
yes I was gonna burst yeah I went one of
the public and now they're fine asking
all these you know new ways because if
we're always on mobile now yeah there's
new ways of advertising find out where
you are and when you're there and
advertising specifically for you that
was I think why they got whether revenue
went up so much as their advertising
dollars are huge because of the mobile
content right well their facebook paper
also now exactly right there now they
have all the journalists knowing all the
big news companies knowing that they can
kind of sort and sift through what
facebook decides to show to people so
now Facebook's controlling the
information that a certain demographic
the people received so that's a lot of
people her net neutrality is gone
that'll also be the way yeah yeah we're
gonna talk more about net neutrality we
did it last week but that that's a whole
other whole thing so do you think that
the the NSA stuff and the spying stuff
and the privacy stuff maybe we'll sort
of begin the ending of Facebook that
maybe we're finally getting to the point
where we don't want to share everything
and we feel like we don't know what
we're sharing so maybe singing from any
who is seeing it and who's using it in
Facebook's closed government and all
kind of stuff that maybe people will
pull back and then ultimately get off
facebook I don't know nothin such a
celebrity culture and I think that
Facebook is a way for your common person
to become their own celebrity you know
they're able to post and show their life
and i think that the culture we live in
kind of i don't see almost a dictates
but kind of feeds into that facebook
mentality and the twitter mentality and
the Instagram mentality of look at me
look where I am suppose you know and and
advertisers as well as find that if if
our eyes are their advertisers will go
where the eyes are ya remember that film
in the kind of film a day without a
mexican i think was ur day without
mexicans somebody made this great film
where they were like what if all the
illegal immigrants and mexicans doing
that work just disappeared from earth
what would people rely on would be like
the apocalypse in California and other
states that rely on it really they
should do a movie like you know a day
without facebook and just watch everyone
logs off of facebook and see if the
world just crumbles I'm serious choking
which everyone to meet I love her there
showed how isolated our world can become
a more all focused on you know thinking
we're connecting everybody but we're
just stuck in this little isolated
insular world all right well maybe we
can start a trend right here I actually
like that idea can we do a day with no
social media i will put down twitter for
a day if you guys are into it comment
down below and maybe well maybe we'll
start a trend what would the hashtag be
um no social media good you should be an
advertising all right let's we got one
more for you let's talk about nightmares
because an interesting study came out at
the University of Montreal scientists
bringing this full circle because they
look into things and give you evidence
and proof of things they found out that
men and women actually have different
nightmares and report different feelings
and emotions during their dreams
nightmares are very disturbing dreams in
which the unpleasant visual imagery and
emotions wake you bad dreams are very
disturbing dreams which do not cause you
to wake up fear appeared as the main
emotion in sixty-five percent of
nightmares and forty-five percent of bad
dreams and almost half of all the
disturbing dreams contain primary
emotions other than fear including anger
sadness guilt and frustration women's
disturbing dreams tend to focus on
social conflicts like friendships and
romances gone wrong men more often
reported sleep jarred by disasters
whether floods or swarms of bugs only
one point five percent of the sampled
nightmares and bad dreams involved
themes of falling I think people always
think of the falling dream have you guys
had the following green ok so we've all
had it but only 1.5 a dream and you've
had the flood the flying one's good too
I've had that one I in your dreams I
always feel like I can't land meets like
I'm going to go yeah like I'm leader
yeah it's like a legend yeah right so
anything what does it need was it yeah
how is this end up flying and I can't
land or don't know how to control the
way yeah you know I'm not scared of like
I don't know like that by fear of helium
so maybe that I miglia phobia so the
disaster thing like just in terms of our
our dreams until do you have the
disaster dreams and the world coming to
an end but I take so much ambien that my
drafts are completely dissipated yeah it
makes you like trip out like this makes
me talk I'm gonna sleep redecorate my
house but you know I don't remember it
yeah so it's all fine I don't know I
think that you know men and women you
know if dreams are kind of how we work
through our daily problems yeah I think
that you know will we also have
different sponsibilities and see the
world through different eyes I think
that's going to affect our you know
subconscious state yeah do you guys
think we don't talk about our dreams
enough because I do feel like it's the
end I can always tell if I have weird
dreams it's because I either was looking
at my phone too late before I went to
bed which I'm trying not to do now so my
brain can slow down or its of course
giving you all this subconscious stuff
that your mind is working through right
but I feel like people don't tell you
someone comes up to know it's like let
me tell you how this dream I had last
night you're like oh like is there
anything worse than that but shouldn't
we be talking about it more I mean I
like talking it I think I hear more
women obviously than men do that like
more women kind of disclose personal or
oh you wouldn't believe what just
happened to me type things anyway and
it's a generalization but I hear lots of
women me like I had the craziest dream
last night more frequently than guys
will say it but you know maybe it isn't
we should be talking through just cuz
sometimes talking things out loud help
you negotiate + dreams weird man I just
like kidding about you guys have any
reoccurring dreams anything that really
like has popped up at or I guess now
you're an ambien this guy doesn't app
you always have not you always buy often
have dreams of you're forgetting what
you're supposed to say you're else and
they throw you in front of the camera
and you've never had the script or yeah
I was find it weird how sometimes
throughout your day you'll experience
something that'll trigger oh my god I
just had this dream about this last
night and I was that's always so odd to
me that you don't remember your dream
sometimes until halfway through the day
when you have an experience that
triggers that dream or this I just I
just thought about this or
so are you saying dreams could be
premonition I don't know it maybe I'm
coming back to that quantum physics
quote ID oh wow we're really bringing a
full circle what about you any real
reoccurring yeah yeah I said well my
biggest reoccurring is the flying i
would say about once a week i have a
dream or I'm either in a flying
situation or something that wouldn't be
flying like I'm in a chair lift for
skiing and also on the chairlift is gone
and that I'm flying and instead of most
people that I've talked about flower
like yeah flying's just so fun instead
of my immediate concern is how do I get
down there and show the fly hopefully
how do I get down and then I have a few
other reoccurring ones i have a weird
apocalypse one well be somewhere and we
know the world is going to end and my
reaction is different in all them
sometimes it's calm sometimes I'm very
freaked out by it I have a lot of
reoccurring theme dream so when I have a
different one it's almost stranger to me
well I can give you the most obvious
reoccurring dream on the planet which is
my main one that I probably once a week
I'm guest hosting the daily show and it
goes incredibly well like perfect
perfect perfect but they forgot to turn
the cameras on all right that's like got
a comedy 101 or something bad yeah that
would be like the most obvious like
you're afraid you're gonna do something
great no one's gonna see it is gonna be
no record of it or the 91 I mother you
go through my day and I'll realize like
I'm totally naked and no one said
anything why have I said anything that
I'm I have never imagined burley that
means you're very free yourself afraid
you're exposing or sound too much yeah I
feel like everyone's dreams I don't know
what the deeper meaning of these things
aren't obviously there's all these dream
books and you can go see dream
consultants but usually if you think
about your dream you know how it makes
you feel yeah I think that's pretty much
how you work it out how does thinking
about this or dreaming about this make
me feel oh do I feel bad about it okay
let's work on it I feel good about it
let's work towards that it's not that
much of a mystery there yeah so final
thought on this and bringing it back to
this study I guess it shouldn't surprise
us right that men and women have
different dreams we use different parts
of our brains and all that kind of stuff
so that does it not surprise you are you
on board you think you have female
dreams sometimes I think I've had some
female dreams if I have them
consistently yeah what are you having
manly dreams every now and again massive
I I do dream more I feel like about the
stuff the mail stuff they're saying I
dream about disasters and things and
more than I dream about people except
for my mother and we won't get into that
because we never Leo my God we're doing
what we do the nightmare dream yes
saying anything she's probably gonna
watch us and be like what does that mean
I'm gonna matter mom I love you mom
we're which cameras and look over to
wreak havoc camera are we going into
switching my axe there no the other one
mom I love you that's perfect that's
poetic all right here we mom I love you
too okay that's it Carol do you wanna
mama love you well we really this is
something some show all right people Jen
Hoffman Gerald McCullough I thank them
subscribe it's right down below leave us
some comments maybe we'll start this
anti social media day thing and you
never know what is possible okay see you
next week